de pouvoir commencer
mesdames et messieurs de la presse merci
pour votre présence et je profite aussi
pour saluer nos collègues sénateurs qui
participent à la mission et qui sont là
ce matin et madame la Présidente aussi
de la délégation au collectivités qui
nous fait l'honneur de sa présence
monsieur le rapporteur cher Mathieu
alors Mesdames et Messieurs nous vous
proposons de vous présenter aujourd'hui
les conclusions du rapport de la mission
d'information sur l'avenir de la commune
et du maire cette mission composée de 21
membres a été lancé en début d'année à
l'initiative du groupe les républicains
et c'est Monsieur Mathieu Darnaud qui en
a été désigné rapporteur et j'en ai
assuré la présidence au cours des six
mois qu'elle aura duré elle nous aura
permis de recueillir la parole des
maires et celle des principales
associations qui les représentent sur
les difficultés qu'il rencontre dans
l'exercice de leur mandat et les
souhaits qu'ils forment pour leur avenir
nous avons conduit quatre déplacements
en Ille-et-Vilaine dans les Vosges en
Haute-Garonne et dans la Somme pour
rencontrer sur le terrain des élus
locaux et nous confronter à des réalités
territoriales différentes enfin à
l'initiative de notre rapporteur notre
mission a lancé deux consultations la
première celle des élus locaux a
rencontré un certain succès puisque près
de 3000 élus ont répondu dans 2093
maires si cette consultation ne présente
pas les caractéristiques méthodologiques
d'un sondage le vaste échantillon des
répondants nous a permis de mieux cerner
les ressorts des difficultés actuelles
des mères et leur souhaits d'évolution
par ailleurs nous avons aussi lancé un
sondage conduit par l'institut CSA sur
la perception des Français à l'égard des
mers et des communes le résultat de ces
deux consultations sont publiées dans le
cadre du rapport de la mission
d'information
nul d'entre nous n'a pu être indifférent
au sujet de notre mission puisque
l'actualité nous a aussi un peu rattrapé
pour les anciens élus que nous sommes
beaucoup à avoir été et certains nous le
sommes encore et pour des sénateurs qui
se tiennent au plus près des
collectivités territoriales s'interroger
sur l'avenir de la commune et des maires
c'était s'interroger sur ce qui fait le
cœur de la démocratie locale dresser un
constat lucide de la situation actuelle
des communes et des maires et chercher à
comprendre les ressorts de la crise qui
traversent est-ce qu'il sait aussi les
pistes pour la surmonter tel était
l'ambition de notre mission
d'information et c'est ce à quoi cet
employé notre rapporteur durant ces 6
mois et je vais lui laisser dès à
présent la parole pour qu'il vous
présente nos principaux constats et nos
recommandations je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente à mon tour de
souhaiter
aux journalistes ici présent et à celles
et ceux qui nous suivent en
visioconférence la bienvenue et les
remercier de l'intérêt qu'ils portent à
notre à notre mission je vous remercie
madame la Présidente chère Maryse
Carrère avec qui nous avons formé
un tandem qui s'est attaché à être à la
fois
utile agile en essayant de nous mettre
aucun des territoires de France parce
que la volonté que nous nourrissions
c'est véritablement de prendre en compte
l'ensemble des situations que peuvent
rencontrer les élus et notamment les
élus municipaux sur les différents
territoires de France je vous remercie
également madame la présidente de la
délégation aux collectivités chers
Françoise Gatel avec laquelle nous avons
l'habitude de travailler en étroite
collaboration et vous dire que
finalement ce rapport c'est aussi un
signe de la constance des propositions
sénatoriales puisque nous nous sommes et
forcés de donner de la résonance et un
écho tout particulier aux travaux qui
ont été commis par la délégation je veux
parler notamment du sujet récent des
secrétaires de mairie je veux également
parler de la question du statut de l'élu
ou des conditions d'exercice des mandats
locaux ainsi que bien sûr le sujet
qu'elle connaît par cœur celui des
communes nouvelles qui constituent selon
nous un outil qu'il convient
d'approfondir et qui est aussi une des
solutions à la crise que nous
connaissons et que l'ensemble des maires
ont bien voulu traduire lorsque nous
avons eu l'occasion de les auditionner
d'ailleurs j'ajoute à ce qu'a dit Marie
Carrère que nous avons aussi beaucoup
auditionné en dehors des des visites de
territoires que nous avons fait et puis
remercier les membres de la
Jean-Michel Arnaud Brigitte devessa
Jean-Marc Boyer parce qu'ils ont été des
membres très actifs de la mission et
c'est aussi à travers eux et grâce à eux
que nous avons pu avoir un maximum
d'élus qui ont souhaité porter
témoignage de ce qu'ils vivent parce que
ce Sénat se rapporte sénatorial cette
mission sénatoriale se veut aussi un
reflet de la situation que rencontre les
élus des différents territoires de
France dans toutes leurs complexité mais
aussi en essayant de définir les
contours des des solutions qui peuvent
s'offrir à eux dire aussi que ce rapport
et c'est important il questionne à
nouveau la démocratie locale et si on a
voulu au travers du titre avis de
tempête sur la démocratie locale
soignant le mal des mers
mettre en exergue ce lien étroit qu'il y
a entre la situation que rencontre les
élus des territoire et la démocratie
locale c'est parce que pour nous la
démocratie locale c'est quelque chose
qui est essentiel à conforter et que
cette crise que nous avons essayé de
décrire sur laquelle nous avons essayé
de poser un diagnostic elle pose en
perspective l'avenir de la démocratie
locale alors l'intérêt de ce rapport
Maryse Carrère l'a dit c'est avant tout
d'établir un diagnostic on a beaucoup
parlé notamment dans les médias de la
situation actuelle alors que l'actualité
rappelle à Longvic que ce soit avec les
problématiques que nous avons
rencontrées avec l'agression et le drame
qui est arrivé à Saint-Brevin que ce
soit il y a quelques jours encore avec
malheureusement les émeutes quatre ont
traversé notre qui a traversé notre pays
pardon avec les conséquences
malheureuses que l'on connaît et qui ont
largement confronté et mis les maires et
les élus locaux en première ligne
pour autant aucun diagnostic et surtout
aucun
rapport n'avait fait état de façon aussi
précise de la situation en documentant
c'est ce que Marie Carrère s'est attaché
à rappeler avec notamment le fait de
mettre en place une concertation via la
plateforme du Sénat et un sondage pour
justement permettre de mesurer quel
était à la fois la vision les attentes
de nos concitoyens par rapport à
l'avenir de la commune à l'avenir de
leurs élus ce qu'ils attendaient très
directement des des élus locaux sur
notre territoire et puis pointer du
doigt les difficultés et la réalité de
ce que vivent les élus du nombre exact
de démission à la fin du mois de mai
puisque ce sont plus de 1079 mères qui
ont démissionné à l'échéance de du 30
mai 2023 mais plus inquiétant encore
quasiment 30 000 élus locaux
démissionnaires depuis le début du
mandat qui est là relativement
supérieure à ce que nous avions connu
par le passé et particulièrement sous le
mandat précédent donc ce diagnostic il
pointe aussi du doigt au travers
notamment du sondage les attentes de la
population française de nos concitoyens
vis-à-vis de la mairie vis-à-vis de la
commune vis-à-vis du maire pour eux la
commune c'est bien sûr l'échelon de base
de la démocratie locale on retrouve la
démocratie locale mais c'est aussi ce
lien particulier de proximité qu'il
nourrissent qu'ils entretiennent avec
leurs élus c'est aussi dans des temps
parfois compliqués avec la succession et
la conjonction de crise que nous venons
de rencontrer un lieu où on peut
s'adresser très directement à ces
représentants et ça je crois que le
sondage le met tout à fait en exergue il
considère que c'est aussi la commune le
lieu de l'efficience c'est important de
le dire parce que dans un temps où il y
a une défiance parfois vis-à-vis des
représentants et de la démocratie
représentative de l'ensemble des élus on
voit bien que le maire échappe quand
même encore à ce constat ce qui est à la
fois rassurant mais ce qui ne doit pas
cacher aussi une réalité parce que même
si la commune reste plébiscitée reste
finalement la première des collectivités
reconnus
apprécié et quasiment plébiscité
notamment au travers des chiffres du
sondage l'élu quel qu'il soit commencer
par le maire le conseiller municipal
n'échappe pas
à la critique collective auxquelles sont
confrontées l'ensemble des des élus de
France par delà ce diagnostic nous avons
donc souhaité nous attacher à définir
bien sûr des pistes qui pouvaient demain
redonner si j'ose dire un peu de souffle
et surtout surtout conforter des élus
l'objectif final étant de les inviter à
se réinvestir parce que nous craignons
en disons les choses très clairement que
2026 soit finalement une séquence
municipale qui est une traduction toute
particulière avec un désengagement fort
des élus alors pour en venir maintenant
très directement aux grands axes de
réflexion et aux propositions que nous
avons formulées nous avons souhaité
vraiment nous attacher à redonner si
j'ose dire ce qu'appelle de leur vœux
les élus plus de liberté dans l'exercice
de leur mandat facilitant par la même ce
lien de proximité cette nécessaire
agilité dans la capacité qu'ils ont à
répondre aux aspirations de nos
concitoyens c'était vraiment la première
partie du rapport comment consacrer
cette France communale cet esprit
communal qui se singularise justement
par cette proximité et cette
revendication si j'ose dire de nos
concitoyens à avoir des élus qui peuvent
mettre en adéquation le dire et le faire
et surtout répondre comme je le disais à
l'instant aux aspirations et au
préoccupations du quotidien nous avons
et c'est pas une première ici au Sénat
ou l'avion déjà fait dans plusieurs
rapports dans plusieurs textes souhaité
constitutionnaliser la clause de
compétences générales des communes
considérant que quand on parle du lieu
de l'efficience du lieu de l'action
faut-il encore que le maire puisse avoir
la capacité la latitude de pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre l'ensemble de ces
projets et d'avoir justement la capacité
à actionner à tout tous les leviers nous
avons souhaité également
réinterroger ce couple commune
intercommunalité ça en remettre
d'ailleurs en cause l'organisation telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui mais peut-être
un changement en changeant quelque peu
de
pradigme et c'est là aussi quelque chose
de nouveau dans ce rapport c'est la
réaffirmation de la territorialisation
de l'action publique que faut-il
entendre par la territorialisation de
l'action publique c'est finalement de
créer un biotope un écosystème local qui
permet peut-être en restant bien sûr
dans le champ constitutionnel dans le
champ de la loi de donner plus de
liberté plus d'agilité aux communes et
finalement de faire de cette union
commune intercommunalité un couple qui
privilégie l'efficience au regard des
problématiques du territoire cela doit
selon nous notamment ce traduire par
peut-être le fait au début de chaque
mandat de revisiter le pacte de
gouvernance le pacte de compétences et
peut-être se dire qu'au regardes de la
situation
liberté soit laissée à l'exécutif des
intercommunalités ça aussi c'est une
demande récurrente du que certaines
compétences puis redescendre au niveau
de la commune et d'autres si le besoin
s'en fait sentir remonter à l'échelon de
l'intercommunalité considérant que les
problématiques des territoires sont
particulièrement différents que là où un
sujet de proximité peut s'exercer au
niveau de l'intercommunalité dès lors
que l'intercommunalité garde une taille
relativement raisonnable elle peut tout
à fait exercer ses compétences de
proximité et qu'à l'inverse quand on
voit ces grandes intercommunalités qu'on
a baptisé XXL où on voit que les
compétences de proximité sont complexes
à exercer parce qu'il y a au sein même
du territoire intercommunal plusieurs
micro territoires c'est ce que nous
avions d'ailleurs essayé de traiter dans
la fameuse loi 3DS avec Françoise Gatel
pour tendre vers ce qu'on a appelé une
intercommunalité à la carte alors le
terme a fait beaucoup parler mais c'est
surtout la capacité encore une fois
d'avoir cette agilité de considérer je
le dis devant Jean-Michel Arnaud que
dans certains territoires de relie de
montagne la compétence haut la
compétence assainissement
peut tout à fait de façon très
pertinente être redonné aux communes
sans que justement cela ne provoque
c'est c'est débats et cette opposition
et d'ailleurs la territorialisation de
l'action publique c'est ça finalement
c'est de se dire que plutôt que
d'opposer ce qui considère que pour
rester sur ce sujet l'eau est
l'assainissement en vocation absolument
être traité par l'intercommunalité mais
tant de côté la problématique du bassin
hydrographique ou du bassin versant
peut-être faut-il redonner cette
latitude et cette capacité de se dire
que dans chaque territoire il y a une
vérité et donc il appartient
singulièrement lorsque les élus
intercommunaux ne souhaitent pas exercer
que la loi ne les oblige pas à exercer
donc vraiment revenir à cette agilité et
puis la territorialisation de l'action
publique c'est aussi dire clairement que
l'État doit aboutir sa déconcentration
c'est que l'État doit être incarné
réellement sur le territoire
carte mentale par le préfet enseigné
coordonnateur de l'action publique j'ai
coutume de dire que l'État ça ne doit
pas ça ne doit pas être pardon cette
hydro Delerm où on aurait un état à
plusieurs têtes avec ici les services
coordonnés par le préfet là des
directions régionales comme la Dréal là
encore la DRAC les services de
l'éducation nationale parce que pour
l'élu les lu local cela devient alors un
parfum un parcours du combattant de
trouver le bon interlocuteur et d'avoir
cette capacité cette agilité à générer
de l'efficience et surtout parce que la
finalité je le dis à l'envie c'est de
satisfaire aux besoins aux exigences de
nos concitoyens et par la même vouloir
simplifier c'est le deuxième axe les
relations entre les communes les
intercommunalités et l'État alors cette
incarnation c'est la première réponse et
puis il faut de la simplification là
encore c'est un sujet que nous avons
essayé de préenter depuis longtemps ici
au Sénat et nous avons notamment
souhaité faire en sorte que par exemple
s'agissant des dotations des fameuses
dotations qui permettent aux communes
d'investir les fameuses dotations
d'équipement des territoires ruraux les
dotations de soutien l'investissement
local et le dernier né la dotation fond
vert puisse finalement être fondu dans
une seule dotation considérant de toute
façon que c'est le projet de loi de
finances qui définit les montants qui
sont après répartis dans les
départements et que c'est le préfet voir
la commission DETR dans certains dans
les départements qui permettent de fixer
les critères d'éligibilité et donc que
rien n'échappe à l'état donc dans le
l'octroi de ces crédits et dans les
conditions d'éligibilité et qu'il n'y a
pas lieu dès lors de faire en sorte que
on puisse imaginer que les élus
viendraient parasiter
ce process là et donc de la
simplification faire en sorte qu'il y
ait un guichet unique parce que là
encore beaucoup de mer nous disent c'est
d'ailleurs la question des normes là
encore largement traitée avec des
réponses par la délégation au
collectivités et cet ensemble de du
parcours du combattant cette chape de
plomb administrative qui parfois
j'allais dire majoritairement décourages
les maires et les élus des territoires
et donc l'idée d'un guichet unique où on
aurait un dépôt de dossiers vis-à-vis de
ces dotations sont pour nous une façon
de répondre justement à cette à ce
besoin de simplification pour rester sur
l'idée de de la simplification et
peut-être de la confiance au sein du
bloc du bloc communal c'est l'idée
encore une fois de donner des outils qui
qui permettront j'allais dire
d'instaurer une véritable
présentation là où on a le sentiment
pour les plus petites communes et elles
sont très majoritaires dans notre
commune comprendre par là
les petites communes au sens
démographiques du terme la capacité de
faire en sorte quand on a notamment des
grandes intercommunalités d'avoir ce
qu'on a appelé un droit de veto alors
c'est pas une opposition stricte c'est
ce qu'on a constaté notamment dans une
agglomération comme le grand Reims 143
communes que la plus petite commune dès
lors qu'on lui impose un projet ou la
prise d'une compétence qui n'est pas
souhaitée elle peut justement faire
valoir ce droit de veto qui permet de
reposer le problème et qui impose entre
guillemets je veux dire à
l'intercommunalité de repenser le sujet
le projet ou le transfert d'une du d'une
compétence donc c'est vraiment mettre
quelque part de l'huile dans les rouages
alors c'est dans le dans la charte de
gouvernance donc on pas sur quelque
chose qui est très normatif mais ça
permet et on l'a vu avec une certaine
efficience de donner le sentiment que
l'intercommunalité dès lors qu'elle est
relativement grande en territoire et en
nombre de communes c'est pas David
contre Goliath quand on a une grande
centralité par rapport au plus petit des
communes et puis troisième grand axe que
nous avons souhaité traiter et là ça
nous ramène au coeur de l'actualité ce
sont les conditions d'exercice des
mandats locaux aujourd'hui il est une
absolue certitude c'est que les élus ont
de plus en plus de mal à exercer leur
mission parce que on l'a dit et c'est
finalement la traduction de la première
partie de ce rapport la complexité
administrative normative à laquelle ils
sont confrontés la difficulté de plus en
plus prégnante parce que la tâche et la
mission est de plus en plus chronophage
à conjuguer vie professionnelle vider lu
parce que la vie familiale devient très
souvent
difficilement conciliables parce que
vous avez aujourd'hui disons les choses
très clairement quand vous êtes amené à
prendre un temps partiel des
problématiques liées aux indemnités là
aussi on a souhaité de façon très
transparente comme nous l'avions fait
dans 3ds reposer la question parce que
sinon ce sont bien des élus qui demain
retourneront vers une activité
professionnelle exclusive et je veux
dire ont tendance auront tendance à
délaisser leur mandat des lieux et puis
c'est aussi comme nous l'avons fait
notamment vis-à-vis des sapeurs-pompiers
prendre en compte ce temps qui est donné
à la collectivité aux autres à l'intérêt
général parce que c'est bon de rappeler
que sur les 520 000 élus locaux une
immense majorité d'entre eux sont des
bénévoles et je dis bien des bénévoles
au service des territoires et il serait
tout à fait normal notamment que dans le
calcul de leur retraite il puisse y
avoir une prise en compte de ce temps
passé au service des autres au service
de la collectivité c'est aussi redéfinir
les questions comme nous l'avions fait
d'informations et de transparence aux
élus par rapport aux obligations qui
leur sont qui leur sont faites par
rapport au sujet notamment concernant le
contour des prises illégales d'intérêt
pour faire en sorte qu'il ait une
véritable information que l'ensemble des
élus puisse être informés comme il se
doit des responsabilités qui sont les
leurs des exigences auxquelles ils
doivent se conformer mais que tout ceci
puisse se faire en bonne en bonne
intelligence et puis c'est aussi traité
comme la délégation je le rappelais la
fée les questions des moyens je pense
notamment aux secrétaire des mairies de
mairies parce que trop souvent nous
sommes confrontés à des communes qui
n'ont plus la capacité à recruter c'est
aussi poser la question à un seul marché
nous le faisait rappeler des
des dotations qui peuvent accompagner
justement ces moyens pour faire
fonctionner nos communes et enfin
dernier point de ce rapport c'est la
fiscalité locale là aussi c'est un sujet
important alors bien sûr nous sommes
attachés à livrer quelques pistes qui
sont là aussi
des des pistes de réflexion et des
positions
réaffirmées au fil du temps par par le
Sénat c'est d'abord ce lien fiscal entre
la commune et le citoyen c'est quelque
chose auquel nous sommes très attachés
considérant que finalement c'est
essentiel et le rapport à la démocratie
locale se comprend parfaitement que le
citoyen est bien conscience des services
que rend la collectivité et du fait que
ces services ne sont pas des services
gratuits que tout cela a un coût et
c'est finalement con substantiel de ce
lien entre le citoyens et la
collectivité c'est aussi les questions
un peu de visibilité là aussi ça a été
une demande de notre collègue à un chien
Larcher mais que tout ce qui contribue à
faire vivre à nos collectivités que ce
soit les fonds de concours comme le
FCTVA les dotations puissent être
communiquées j'allais dire le plus en
amont possible pour que notamment et ça
c'est vrai dans les petites comme dans
les communes les plus importantes les
maires et la visibilité souhaité pour
pouvoir mener à bien leurs projets et
pouvoir anticiper au maximum les choses
c'est important dans un temps économique
que l'on sait aussi compliqué après des
plans de relance successifs qui
concomitant aux différentes crises que
nous venons que nous venons de traverser
que notre pays a traversé voilà
très j'allais dire de façon très
succincte
les différents axes et les quelques
pistes alors le rapport
et beaucoup plus exhaustif et vous
trouverez j'allais dire beaucoup de
réponses
aux axes et aux questions que nous
posons aux orientations que nous
souhaitons poursuivre mais la
philosophie de ce rapport c'est vraiment
redonner de la liberté de l'agilité au
bloc communal et puis redonner une
capacité à agir parce que et ça sera mon
mot de conclusion on a quand même le
sentiment d'une forme de désespérance
chez l'ensemble des aides de France qui
n'est d'une d'un sentiment mais aussi
d'une réalité qui est devenu de plus en
plus compliqué d'agir et surtout de
répondre aux exigences de nos
concitoyens ce qui peut créer les
conditions justement d'une crise en
matière de démocratie locale c'est ce
que nous souhaitons à tout prix éviter
considérant que il est une chose qui
fonctionne particulièrement bien dans
notre pays c'est cette cette France
communale cet esprit communal parce
qu'il a lié à la fois proximité comme je
en préambule efficience et c'est aussi
une part de l'identité de chacune et de
chacun de nos concitoyens un territoire
qui est celui de l'attachement le lieu
c'est le lien et je pense que nous avons
essayé dans ce rapport encore une fois
on considère tous les acteurs qui
participent à la vie démocratique locale
de redonner des pistes et du souffle à
cette à cette France communale voilà en
tout cas merci de votre attention puis
je crois que maintenant on est tout à
fait disposé à répondre à vos questions
oui
sans avoir en face la capacité d'y
répondre et les conditions au quotidien
pour pour y répondre ça c'est la
première des conditions la seconde elle
n'est de la difficulté à terme devant
une mission qui est de plus en plus
chronophage à conjuguer alors
singulièrement dans ce mandat 2020-2026
parce que c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas
omettre la complexité du début de mandat
lié à la crise sanitaire à la difficulté
de créer du lien singulièrement dans les
communes qui ont vu des équipes
municipales renouvelées avec des
nouveaux maires des nouveaux adjoints
qui n'avaient pas nécessairement
j'allais dire le recul la pratique et
l'habitude et dès lors ça devient très
compliqué de fonctionner et surtout de
conjuguer dans l'ensemble de ces
communes qui sont démographiquement
moins peuplées et qui imposent à l'élu
sauf à considérer qu'il soit retraité de
conjuguer à son activité d'élus avec
son son ou ses mandats et c'est vrai que
ça c'est relativement complexe voilà ça
c'est vraiment les les deux les deux
raisons dominantes après s'agissant de
cette raison liée au violence auquel
sont confrontées les élus permettez-moi
d'en dire un mot alors ça n'est pas
simplement les violences qui ont
malheureusement été relayés
médiatiquement celle de Saint-Brévin
celle de Vincent Jean Brun là il est
rose par rapport aux émeutes que nous
venons de vivre mais c'est au quotidien
dans tous les territoires de France les
plus urbains comme les plus ruraux des
élus qui sont confrontés à toutes les
formes de violence et je dis bien à
toutes les formes de violence parce que
ça peut être bien sûr et malheureusement
la violence physique mais c'est aussi la
violence morale c'est la violence des
réseaux sociaux quand on stigmatise on
pointe du doigt on dit femme on accuse
gratuitement un maire par rapport à un
projet par rapport à une action qu'il a
voulu engagé par rapport à des
orientations qu'ils souhaitent prendre
et là on a un vrai sujet parce qu'il
faut conjuguer bien sûr avec l'exigence
en matière de liberté d'expression mais
d'appréhender tant que faire ce peu des
outils comme les réseaux sociaux qui
sont aussi une capacité d'expression
très directe parfois brutale vis-à-vis
des élus et qui sont la source d'une
forme de démotivation donc c'est
vraiment prendre la question des
violences dans leur ensemble s'agissant
des violences physiques nous avons
déposé une proposition de loi avec
François de Noël buffet avec Françoise
Gatel Maryse Carrère et puis président
de de groupe pour justement dénoncer
cette violence aux élus en renforçant
l'échelle des peines en traitant aussi
des candidats parce que avant d'être élu
faut-il encore être candidat et souvent
les candidats eux-mêmes sont confrontés
finalement et en restaurant assez
violent et en considérant que les élus
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
et que l'échelle des peines doit
finalement être arrimés ou être élevé
aux peines qui s'appliquent dès lors
qu'on s'en prend à toute personne dépose
de terre de l'autorité publique aux
forces de de sécurité notamment donc ça
c'est essayer d'apporter vraiment une
une réponse mais il faut vraiment
traiter le sujet dans son ensemble et ne
pas omettre ces sujets quotidiens de
violence en tout cas d'agression
verbales auxquelles sont confrontées les
élus et qui parfois
sont source de découragement
bonjour Thomas fraise pour Public Sénat
vous parlez d'ingénierie de secrétaire
de mairie
et d'autres propositions auxquelles vos
collègues ont déjà apporté des
propositions eux aussi au cours des deux
derniers mois quelle est la finalité de
toutes ces propositions est-ce que c'est
de s'inscrire dans différentes plans
que vos collègues aussi portent ou alors
de créer un grand plan de sauvetage des
mairies
alors 3
3 éléments de réponse le première
réponse j'aime à le dire et à le redire
je crois et on la redit avec le
président Larcher la semaine dernière à
l'occasion de la présentation du groupe
de travail sur la décentralisation
qu'aujourd'hui le Sénat se distingue par
la constance de ses propositions
nous avons commis avec Jean-Marie
Bocquel et la délégation collectivités
un rapport sur le statut de l'élu en
2018 déjà qui finalement reprend à peu
près tous les sujets qui sont
aujourd'hui sur la table et dont la
première ministre pardon à Dominique
Faure elle-même dit qu'il donnerait lieu
un diagnostic qui serait partagé avec
l'ensemble des associations d'élus moi
je lui dis chiche plutôt que de perdre
du temps dans la concertation les
problèmes pardon de le dire mais nous
qui auditionnons là je parle devant tous
mes collègues parce que sont les
premiers concernés ils le font eux-mêmes
dans leur territoire ils le font même au
travers des différents travaux qu'ils
ont été amenés ici au Sénat pardon mais
les problèmes
lié aux conditions d'exercices des
membres du mandats locaux on les connaît
il n'y a pas besoin de reposer un énième
diagnostic qui va nous faire perdre
encore six mois le Sénat les a déjà
largement expertisé et on a toutes les
pistes de solutions qui sont qui sont
sur la table donc je pense que si
vraiment le gouvernement aspire à se
saisir de ce sujet il peut il peut le
faire très directement bien sûr sans
omettre la concertation tout à fait
légitime avec avec les associations donc
la première chose c'est vraiment de dire
voilà ce travail c'est difficulté ce mal
des élus c'est pas la première fois
qu'on le pointe du doigt c'est pas la
première fois qu'on parle de l'avenir de
la commune c'est pas la première fois
qu'on met sur le tapis des propositions
quel que soit leur nature deuxième chose
c'est que on a toujours essayé de donner
à ces sujets une traduction législative
lorsque nous avions commis le rapport
sur les 50 propositions en juillet 2020
avec un groupe de travail
transpartisan ici même sous la
présidence de Gérard Larcher là encore
la volonté c'est d'avoir donné quelques
mois plus tard une traduction
législative et la troisième réponse
c'est de se dire qu'à un moment donné il
faut pas se cacher derrière son petit
doigt c'est à dire qu'il y a beaucoup de
sujets qui n'ont pas besoin d'une
traduction législative ce que j'ai dit
s'agissant notamment de la question de
la déconcentration faire du préfet le
coordonnateur des services de l'État sur
le département
l'État peut tout à fait décider dès
demain qu'elle va justement agir très
fortement dans ce sens et donc par la
même générer de la simplification la
question que nous avons évoqué sur le
champ communal le fait de donner plus de
simplicité d'agilité on peut tout à fait
le faire parce que aujourd'hui la loi
offre des outils qui sont déjà en
vigueur je pense notamment à un sujet
que
encore nous avions été rapportés avec
Françoise Gatel sur la simplification de
l'expérimentation c'est un sujet pour
lequel il a fallu légiférer à la hate en
2021 et dont aucune collectivité ne sait
aujourd'hui saisie le gouvernement et
l'État n'en faisant absolument pas la
promotion et qui selon moi pourrait
permettre
finalement
d'expérimenter des sujets sur sur
certains territoires d'autant qu'on a
facilité la sortie de l'expérimentation
et qu'aujourd'hui on a plus à
généraliser ce qui était un vrai un vrai
sujet donc on a aujourd'hui des outils
et puis bien sûr celui que j'évoquais
c'est à dire le statut de l'élu on peut
avancer il y a pas besoin à chaque fois
de repasser par la loi il faut avancer
et je pense que la finalité aussi de ce
rapport c'est de dire comme on l'a dit
sur le groupe de travail sur la
décentralisation
qu'aujourd'hui la première des choses
c'est qu'il faut une volonté politique
pour répondre aux problématiques des
élus il faut une volonté politique et il
faut que le gouvernement se saisisse des
propositions que nous avons fait
on n'a pas la volonté et on n'a pas la
prétention de dire que seul le Sénat a
travaillé sur ces sujets mais que
beaucoup de sujets encore une fois ont
déjà des réponses qui qui mériteraient
d'être actionnées dans l'urgence
je sais pas si il y a d'autres questions
je me tourne vers les
alors on nous dit que
oui je crois que c'est bon ce beurré je
crois qu'il faut que vous actionnez
votre votre micro
c'est bon merci c'est parfait
oui donc vous vous portez au chevet de
la démocratie locale
mais pour
revigorer cette démocratie locale je
m'interroge et ce qu'il ne faut pas
s'intéresser
non seulement au maire comme vous le
faites mais aussi aux oppositions
municipales
parce que comme vous le savez les droits
de l'opposition municipale sont assez
réduits
et
[Musique]
sur le plan national
je pense qu'on serait choqué si les
droits de l'opposition étaient aussi
réduits qu'ils le sont localement et en
parallèle est-ce qu'il ne faut pas
baisser la prime majorité qui donne une
très peut-être trop vaste majorité à la
liste qui arrive en tête plus élections
municipales voilà donc je voulais poser
ces deux questions alors pour y répondre
et je pense que c'est enfin c'est
sincèrement une
une complexité de l'exercice auquel nous
sommes confrontés
la commune c'est à la fois un ensemble
c'est à la fois un échelon de
l'échelon de base de la démocratie
locale mais c'est aussi des réalités
communales qui sont très différentes
lorsque
l'on parle d'opposition faut-il encore
définir ce qui est une opposition dans
une commune de 500 habitants de
habitants et une opposition dans une
commune de 1020 ou 30 000 habitants
c'est très important de le dire parce
que il ne faut surtout pas me connaître
et elles sont largement majoritaires les
communes les moins dans ces monts
peuplés il ne faut pas méconnaître que
dans la l'immense majorité des cas on
m'a pas une liste qui se compose sur des
sensibilités politiques c'est avant tout
des listes qui sont là au service du
territoire qui ont d'ailleurs en leur
sein différentes sensibilités parce que
de toute façon on va pas faire des
listes politiques dans dans ces communes
là donc forcément la question des droits
à l'opposition elle se pose dès lors
qu'on a une majorité une opposition
constituée parce que le prisme politique
n'est pas le seul à définir une majorité
une opposition on peut aussi définir une
majorité une opposition sur des projets
donc effectivement il est important de
faire en sorte que tout ceci soit soit
soit respecté pour être très honnête
avec vous c'est une question que nous
avons posée c'est une question
sachant qu'on a vraiment laissé le champ
le plus ouvert le plus libre à
l'ensemble des élus à l'ensemble des
associations à l'ensemble de celles et
ceux que nous avons interrogé questionné
qui n'est pas ressorti le
plus souvent voire pas ressorti du tout
pour autant c'est quelque chose que que
je peux entendre sur lequel nous avons
déjà fait porter une une réflexion mais
je pense que vraiment pour y répondre il
faut bien distinguer les les deux
catégories de de communes parce que
encore une fois l'opposition ne se
traduit pas nécessairement de la même
manière on est tout à fait disposé à
expertiser j'allais dire qu'on a et vous
le verrez dans le rapport essayez
d'aller le plus loin dans l'expertise
dans l'ensemble des sujets qui ont été
traités mais c'est vrai qu'on peut
encore pousser un peu plus loin
le sujet est peut-être le ferons-nous on
l'avait déjà évoqué dans plusieurs dans
plusieurs textes ici ici au Sénat voilà
pour autant sincèrement c'est pas un
sujet clairement sur lequel l'accent a
été mis sur la prime sur la prime
majoritaire encore une fois je pense que
oui c'est un c'est un sujet on a même
évoqué d'autres d'autres sujets dans la
droite ligne de ce que vous dites
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui la première
des difficultés alors là pour le coup
elle est ressortie telle qu'elle c'est
la difficulté à trouver dans les plus
petites communes 9 ou 11 candidats dans
dans une commune ça c'est une réalité
absolue aujourd'hui et de nous poser la
question très directement s'il n'y a pas
lieu à s'interroger sur la diminution de
nombre de conseillers et de conseillers
municipaux dans les communes parce
qu'aujourd'hui avec la meilleure volonté
du monde et faisant fit justement de
toutes les formes d'opposition
considérant que les oppositions peuvent
s'exprimer dans une liste qui se
présente même unis devant les devant les
électeurs et ben il faut arriver à
trouver ces neuf 11 ou plus
personne qui qui se porte candidat là il
y a sincèrement un véritable un
véritable sujet donc oui pourquoi pas
les questions que vous posez elles
restent ouvertes en tout cas elles n'ont
pas été exprimées et vraiment je je le
dis et j'en remercie à nouveau
l'ensemble des membres de la mission je
crois qu'on a élu des aucun sujet y
compris le rapport entre nos concitoyens
et la démocratie locale y compris la
question de la démocratie participative
comment on invite nos concitoyens à se
prononcer
quels outils on donne aux maires pour
pour concerter pour le faire avec
quelques règles du jeu je crois qu'on a
eu plusieurs séquences de de travail
avec des maires qui se sont livrés à
l'exercice et là dans les plus petites
comme dans les plus grandes communes
donc voilà ce sont des ce sont des
sujets donc oui
[Musique]
oui monsieur foret pour la gazelle des
communes me dit-on
oui monsieur foret faut juste que vous
mettiez votre votre micro parce qu'a
priori là on le voit couper
voilà ça a l'air allez-y
allez-y on vous entend
on a un sujet on ne vous entend plus
y a-t-il d'autres personnes qui
demandent
ouais si vous avez un sujet peut-être
vous pouvez vous oui
on vous entend peut-être mettre plus
fort le
sinon vous pouvez nous écrire aussi la
question si vous le si vous le souhaitez
peut-être le temps que l'on règle s'il y
a une autre question
allez-y
comment les mers vont-ils exprimer leur
blouse à l'occasion des sénatoriales
j'imagine c'est ça
alors pour être très honnête nous ne
leur avons pas posé la question
[Rires]
mais
voilà comme le dit Jean-Marc Boyer vous
pouvez être sûr que vous serez fixé
d'ici
trois mois non pour répondre pour
répondre de façon plus plus sérieuse je
crois que nous avons là aussi
intérêt à essayer parce que par
définition et
parce que le Sénat est avant tout la
chambre des territoires une vocation et
une envie cheville au corps mais depuis
maintenant plusieurs années je rappelais
tout à l'heure la constance des
propositions sénatoriales la volonté et
je crois que elle est intacte et
j'allais dire peut-être même décuplé
chez les collègues sénatrices et
sénateurs c'est vraiment d'essayer
d'apporter des solutions très concrètes
je prends l'exemple notamment
des sujets qui revenus sur tous les
territoires qui a été porté par toutes
les associations d'élus quelle qu'elle
soit
intercommunalité de France que ce soit
les maires de France que ce soit les
mers ruraux y compris qui transparaît
dans le dans la concertation et dans le
sondage c'est le rapport à l'état disons
les choses très clairement je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a le sentiment
malheureusement
exprimé de façon très différente selon
les interlocuteurs mais qu'il est devenu
de plus en plus difficile
de conjuguer et de faire en sorte que
déconcentration et décentralisation avec
de père et face à un besoin
d'immédiateté auquel sont confrontés les
maires il y a un temps et un manque
d'agilité au niveau de des services
déconcentrés de l'État alors qui ne met
surtout pas en cause la bonne volonté
des préfets des sous-préfets qui
paraissent être même plutôt ces
personnes plébiscitées pour être comme
je le disais les ensembler les
coordonnateurs de l'action publique sur
les territoires mais par rapport aux
moyens dont elle dispose elle-même je
vous prends un exemple vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure quelqu'un a parlé de la
question de l'ingénierie question de
l'ingénierie elle est réelle mais
aujourd'hui pardon de le dire c'est
c'est très compliqué parce que sur la
l'ingénierie on a plus qu'une politique
en silo vous avez l'ingénierie des
collectivités qui existent et qui
fonctionnent plutôt bien vous avez
l'ingénierie de l'État qui passe
aujourd'hui par toute cette politique
d'appel à projets qui est porté par
l'anct avec les petites villes de demain
action cœur de ville et qui avec France
ruralité maintenant on va s'intéresser
au village et puis vous avez
c'est personne c'est ces techniciens qui
vont être recrutés dans les dans les
préfectures pour l'encore nourrir
l'ingénierie d'état vous en conviendrez
c'est pas le biais le plus simple pour
pour répondre à la fois la politique
d'appel à projet pour répondre à la
volonté de nourrir des projets dans les
plus petites intercommunalités ou les
plus petites communes de France et donc
on a vraiment vraiment besoin de porter
et nous le portons ici au Sénat
l'idée que l'État aboutisse sa
déconcentration encore une fois dans un
souci déficience et de et de
simplification
y a-t-il d'autres questions
c'est bon
voilà bah écoutez a priori il n'y a pas
d'autres questions en tout cas nous
restons tout à fait
attentif
aux questions que vous pourriez être
amenées à vous poser à la lecture du du
rapport et pour des informations
complémentaires encore une fois je tiens
à remercier à la fois bien sûr la
présidente de la mission d'information
parce que nous a permis vraiment de
concerter de d'être à l'écoute du
maximum d'élus des territoires
l'ensemble des membres de de la mission
qui ont été particulièrement proactifs
et qui nous ont fait eux-mêmes remonter
les aspirations des différents
territoires dans lesquels ils sont ils
sont élus en nous permettant notamment
de rencontrer des mères qui sont
confrontés au quotidien des
problématiques particulières et quand je
dis merci des élus intercommunaux donc
voilà un grand merci en tout cas à votre
entière disposition et surtout vous
remercier de l'intérêt que vous avez
porté à nos travaux que nous essaierons
de porter de traduire demain dans un une
démarche législative voilà je vous
remercie